van a reanudar teherán y washington las
negociaciones sobre el espinoso problema
nuclear iraní
nuestra prevista ninguna discusión
directa para el martes en la reunión
entre delegaciones en viena el jefe de
la diplomacia iraní lo recordó en
twitter el objetivo es finalizar
rápidamente el levantamiento de
sanciones y las medidas contra la
energía nucleoeléctrica si reunión entre
eeuu e irán es inútil sin embargo una
delegación estadounidense estará
presente en la capital austriaca y
estará junto a los otros poderes
firmantes del acuerdo de 2015 china
rusia francia alemania reino unido y la
unión europea probablemente deberían
actuar como intermediarios entre las dos
partes estamos negociando una lista de
bonos nucleares y una lista de
levantamiento de sanciones deberían
fusionarse en algún momento a fin de
cuentas tenemos un enfoque similar creo
que podemos conseguirlo en menos de dos
meses se está acabando el tiempo para
los europeos que quieren evitar que irán
adquiera armas nucleares pero teherán
sigue produciendo uranio enriquecido más
allá de los límites establecidos por el
acuerdo de 2015 una forma con la que han
presionado
antes del texto desde la retirada
estadounidense del acuerdo que fue
decidida unilateralmente por el
expresidente donald trump en 2018 y que
fue acompañada por el restablecimiento
de las sanciones económicas
estadounidenses los temas principales
que serán debatidos son las medidas
nucleares que debe tomar irán para
volver a ser respetado plenamente bajo
los términos del acuerdo de 2015 así
como las sanciones que debe levantar
eeuu para que se vuelva a restaurar pero
teherán establece sus condiciones no
habrá discusión directa antes del
levantamiento de todas las sanciones